[Musique]
chaque fois qu'ils disent bébé, alors l'invocation de
notre monde sonne donc c'est l'éteint dans
la maison, donc nous avons l'écran de la caméra
et cela nous permet qu'ils disent bébé dans la
poubelle, ils envisagent l'adoption car vous
jetez un bébé les visages osseux  les
rues à l'extérieur donc nous
ne savons généralement pas qui
sont ces mamans parce que nous voulons respecter le
désir de rester anonyme
[Musique]
dans un sens les bébés amenés ici sont
les chanceux que nous avons eu des bébés qui
sont venus  pour nous qui avons été trouvés
attachés dans un sac en plastique avec vous savez
si le vrai nœud dedans et jeté
sous un buisson
alors que nous applaudissons Belinda et et
schlaf secundus ppi la colère le pardon peut
sauter le dialogue rashidun et accélérer
donner le muta sen peut stimuler
contenu Hindon supplémentaire dans un contact doux un
monsieur beibahab ou un script et une
oda embarrassante évoquée et vida en
han do ouvre-diffuseur et fatigue et
cantines dans la maison de Midna nommée Connie
[Musique]
retour whate'er chikuwa catalogue Kotoko tambri
et encore jamón jamón jamón
sauce tomate Nikita
Brevet d'Ariane ou Pollen de Swindon
Ramanuja
[Musique]
toi toi